everybody we're gonna start our first
lecture today and I don't know if you
know but right now the Chess Olympiad is
going on it's a very big event that
happens to be every two years and the US
team is playing they're playing very
well so far and but there was a lot of
big obsess today so today I want to show
you one of the games well
Vladimir Kramnik was playing with the
white pieces against grandmasters TomSka
from Poland
so Kramnik is okay let's say close to
2800 his opponent was 2600 so the 200
point upset and crammed Lika lost this
game in fact he got made it actually
checkmate on the board and Russian team
lost to Poland so the biggest upset of
the Olympia so far two and a half for
Poland 1 and 1/2 for Russia so-so
TomSka is the player with the white
pieces and black is Kramnik so we have a
45 Knight f3 knight c6 d4
very sharp start on the white playing
the Scotch takes 94 night of six okay if
white plays Knight c3 here then black
can pretty much equalize with the bishop
before 96 BC Bishop d3 castles castles
d5 it leads to a relatively relatively
balanced position okay so this is a
common theory here white plays Queen f3
so why didn't want to do that so you
went for the knight c6 line it's a
little bit less popular the very sharp
now if I white is immediately
questioning the night Queen e7
now it's pinning the cleaner spinning so
obviously so you cannot capture so and
also you try to take the pawn and what
is the the theoretical move here for
white so because if if you just play a
Ford and you can play a d6 so that
wouldn't be that good so what's the
normal move here a white place Caleb
Queen e2 protecting the pawn and also
that way on pinning the pin Knight d5
now plate h4 aggressive move by white
trying to gain space and also he wants
to put the bishop on g5 okay it's why I
think h4 and putting the bishop on g5 to
attack the Queen at some point night
sorry Queenie six first act you know
moving the Queen so that way the bishop
can have a scope
g3 plate and now a very interesting move
by Kramnik night - before preparing
Bishop a6 idea and now the idea to play
Bishop a6 c4s plate so Bishop a6 doesn't
count with the temple but bish basics
played anyhow Bishop f4 protecting
protecting the pawn so let's try to see
here if white just plays the move a tree
here right I just plays a tree what do
you think would be the best option for
black here Isis Bishop takes c4
quint XE 424 Bishop takes Knight C to
check
where to put the King here question Asst
so you have to
let's say I go here
and wondering if this is there a way to
try to track they know it's there a way
to trap the night
so maybe play why if white had just you
know B 3 B should be to that that would
work so maybe B 3 group be a king C 3
the idea is to play Bishop b2 d5 yeah
that's that problem takes Bishop d6
right maybe maybe one context and then
d5 yeah
so it's very sharp it looks like black
is doing absolutely fine here he doesn't
because it you cannot really get the
nanite trapped immediately so this
doesn't quite work too well so I think I
think a white was not very familiar with
opening because very quickly you see he
found himself in big trouble Bishop f4 I
think already a dubious move and now
chronic played a very strong move here
let's see who can find Kramnik respond
here what more did he play you want to
try to attack the center okay
what can you do to attack the center
new little better little better than
that more active more active to break
the center you want to really break the
center here what is the idea to do it
huh to attack this d5 you have a bishop
here putting pressure right on a6
attacking so you want to play d5 okay to
put pressure now a lot a lot of pressure
on this diagonal we see a three
a tree plate and now the night is
trapped no choice what you have to do
here
correct daddy Queen d1 again this is the
game TomSka versus Kramnik played today
actually at a chess olympiad
in Batumi Georgia what is the move here
here Vladimir Kramnik is winning and he
missed the winning move here bit
surprising here with words the idea here
what he could have done to get the win
Caleb
okay that's interesting absolutely
Queen takes f5 now what the first of all
what is your main threat two of them
actually
Queenie for check winning the rook and
also nicely to check two important
threats you have so after Queen f5 if he
takes 24 check King d2
clean h1 and it takes
and up a exchange with a winning
position and if you place the move
Bishop takes c4 if you place the move
Bishop c4 then what can you do here
kneel when you four check King D -
correct
or castle maybe better yet castle check
and simply winning the Queen and the
game I mean he missed this idea so I
played Bishop takes f1 now rook takes
King takes well now the knight has to
retreat block is still doing great here
but it's not winning here 93-95 before
now black played a very interesting move
here let's see who can find Kramnik
response here the before attacking the
knight on c5 Michael
absolutely d4 instead of moving his
knight you push the pawn on d4 attacking
and now if he captures look at that fork
attacking the Queen and attacking the
rook excellent idea because otherwise
you have to go back to d7 okay
so you go to Queen d7 97 and maybe Queen
before it's not as active 97 maybe
kimchi - so this way it's very active so
he took takes and now the next move
which was pretty shocking now black is
threatening to take on c5 it looks like
he's very close to just be winning here
he's up upon and black king is on f1 and
this is the the moment that it was
pretty very surprising at least to me
that crummy dream played this move here
it's a very natural and a very strong
move here after which black has a very
large advantage in endgame so what is
the move here that will force that Caleb
excellent I guess when I said endgame
that give you a little hint that there
is a queen trade of course now attacking
the Queen and attacking the rook
so if it takes you take so now kindiy
three just sorry you take on so proud
Bishop III
now if long castle he wants to put the
bishop on D for what would be the
correct plan here what would be the
correct one here for white for black
here to get the advantage
that's the right idea here or do you
think Isis rook b8 that's an idea
okay there's an idea that's not that
kinky - maybe
Caleb there you go there you go
you want that king on c6 okay you go
Sears take
okay
extra pawn and you can hide back on CSUN
if route be one you just played rugby
eight very nice advantage yeah this was
a big mistake not to trade queens
because black gets checkmated here takes
okay 25 still attacking the rook Bishop
c5 oxy one putting pressure
okay it could play Bishop d4 here you
know force force they exchanged in that
case I think Quincy six needs to be
played there should be maybe even
slightly better for black but grabbing
per thought he's just winning here or
has a very large advantage so h6 plate
now things are getting a little bit
tricky because now this rook is gonna
come into the game and there is some age
six threats so and if you play aged six
yourself here which we normally do then
it could be there's some e6000 with just
seven hanging hero cage for Luke g6
ideas are out there too so things are
not so clear anymore so that was a huge
missed opportunity here for him
I mean he if he was gonna play Queen if
I have just better I'll just play Queen
d5 here to force the exchange
castle now when you push the pawn all
the way to h5 what do you do yes
h6 of course
yeah now if they drew caffee eight I
think a better office to keep the age
file closed even though this looks a
little bit dangerous but I think he's
better off to play g6 he probably was
concerned about a succession because if
you play off six rounds into a problem
what we said on but actually this is no
problem take what It's Made on g7 Ashish
you have to go B should be forth and
take yeah this is there's probably no
advantage here but at the same time
block is not worse okay it's for sure
not gonna lose this game strange
decision if they'd here I'll take now if
somehow the screen gets the H file it's
gonna be some serious problems so rookie
six Bishop g5 Queen a to a clever move
attacking on f2 with a mate look h2
white calmly defends the problem now is
for black does rook on h2 is an
excellent defender
it protects a2 and also constantly
putting pressure on h7 as well okay and
here where kramnik blundered he played a
move rook d5 better off just to play
Bishop Bishop d4 here was his best move
rook d5 blunder
who can tell me why this is a blunder
and how is this move losing
by the way the rook was under attack so
he had to do something that's why you
have to calculate nail heads
you have to calculate
Tinka sheesh kramnik missed this idea
you've seen the game oh you saw the news
on Chester come okay alright please
raise your hand if you know the winning
idea yes
excellent excellent yes Queen before
threatening nothing else than a
checkmate okay and if you take the pawn
then there's pf6 check and now we see
that the complete disaster here for
block he has to play c5
but that blocks his Bishop on b6 and now
Queen h4 swing in this side and now we
see the importance you know that we
talked about this h-file
and now white is putting pressure
threatening made and the rook is doing a
fantastic job guarding two squares B 1
and C 2 guarding those both squares so
there is no way to defend against h7 so
he played h6
trying to at least delay the mate what
do you do here again it's not still not
too late to make a mistake and let
Khurana get back into the game here it's
still not too way to make a mistake so
what did he play Grandmaster TomSka
Tomczak Bishop f6
but that's allow school to play Michael
Rock d2 and there is some counter play
okay Caleb Bishop is blocked so that we
don't have the F to check unfortunate so
so Bishop f6 okay but are going to maybe
they still taken
Queeny children Quincy
the rookie one checks
okay that should be losing hey Bishop f6
is another move that most likely is
winning I like to move in a game so is
there anything wrong with you taking the
pawn h6
then you take it no need to take it and
then you're ready to move your bishop
back you're ready to move your bishop
back with a mating threat so if it Queen
b3 last attempt to complicate matters
black doesn't even have a check here to
complicate the position so he goes here
threatening group d1 check and the final
move a nice finishing touch by Polish
Grandmaster here
nice touch by the polish grandmasters
here
should be more hands more hands the
threat is rook d1 right how are we gonna
stop it
Adi absolutely Bishop d2 look at that
move
stopping that rook d1 and now treading a
very strong Queen to h8 mate so chemic
played King takes g7 and he allowed the
mate in to check I'm not sure I think he
didn't mind the fact he's getting made
it so he just allowed the actual
checkmate on the board okay this is very
very tough defeat and cos Russia the
match Poland Poland defeated Russia
today at Olympiad and that's the big
news the biggest upset so far we have
okay so you guys understand the idea so
it was too big blunders here played by
chronic in this game very
uncharacteristic of him because he's
such a great player here the first
blunder is huge where he's actually in a
winning position basically all he needs
to do is find which move Queen a5 and
look at those multiple threats out there
92 Queenie forecheck big problems
I'm not sure what he missed here because
you're looking for when opponent is
undeveloped you're looking for ideas
like this to create threats it's
puzzling
so it takes Queenie four and the second
surprising moment was we played a good
move and they reached this position
white is in big big trouble here twenty
four and again what's the most natural
move what is the move that you would
play in this position absolutely Queen
d5 I'm doubling the double pawns
exchanging the Queens so there's no more
attack left
once the Queens come off the board right
so he has to take and now King is coming
in you don't really have time to play
something like c6 because then you're
not getting the palm back Bishop c5 King
g7 and d4 I'm not returning this pawns
now this pawns are to be very strong
they likely to decide the outcome of
this game so very strange very strange
we see that 25 was missed takes and now
things got complicated okay great great
job guys now we're gonna do some
difficult positions okay some top
Grandmaster games that you have to find
the ideas so this is a game between
young Iranian Grandmaster Fallujah
Fallujah versus 3f Alex e3 of black to
play and win as you can see black is
dominating he's got active rooks Queen
knight on d3 bishop and things went
wrong definitely here for a few job
but how can you find a way to break
through here to get the victory yeah
this is something you want to spend some
time because it's lots of calculation
okay you have to play like a strong
almost 2700 grandmasters
white 3f Alexandria who is actually
coming to st. Louis to play in the
upcoming Fall Classic in a group so I
will be facing him so I'm also playing
in that tournament that's my next event
so it's a very experienced Russian Grand
Master
whoo yeah hammer yeah it's gonna be an
interesting event a lot of interesting
players yeah it's very even evenly
matched tournament
everybody is between 26:52 26:30 yeah
we're talking about winning I'm not just
talking about improving move creating
threads something very strong night see
one rook takes c1
due to the night captures yeah yeah
actually this idea if our abyssion was
just here with the window
awesome yeah Rudy one mates I mean
perfect combination
yeah just we just need the bishop there
so like in this position so here here we
just need to put just push the bishop
right here and then we take take slack
and mate on the one all right well it's
a little bit harder than that you know
so I have given this position to some
very top players including some
grandmasters to solve okay so it's a
it's a tough one
lots of calculation required Neal Bishop
d2 and he finds the first move how did
you even think about the two I have four
pieces guarding that square Neal
okay impressive very impressive Bishop
d2 putting the bishop on the square
where these four pieces can capture tell
us why each of them don't work
checkmate
checkmate
and if it takes the Queen
and now you have discovered a check
coming and this is just completely
hopeless so let's see if you calculate
it very impressive so far let's see if
you calculate the outcome after this
you're down the full piece so far but
the good news is White's pieces are
paralyzed they cannot move anything
the knife cannot move the Queen is
saying and the bishop cannot move rook
so there is stuck
which pawn is your target here that you
want to take to get to his King huh
perfect threating mate now
b3
Michael
Quincy tricking me one Isis
why pond takes
mmm-hmm Messier better simpler exelon Rd
go
mm-hm
perfect now threatening checkmate on
checkmate on a - so he has to go here
Neal takes
that's how Graham a surgery if one the
game all right tough one I know but you
know you won't always do difficult
positions because then easier comes will
be much easier to see lots of
calculation here but you have to look
for ideas like this you have to realize
that the big big idea is that the bishop
on c1 there is the piece that is
protecting the position that's the piece
you wanna try to move and here you want
to get a queen on c2 that is a very
important idea and here that's why
Bishop d2 will do the job okay why to
play and win
why to play in black white player is
Yoruba Logan 26 undergrads against Anton
core above another high rank almost 2700
Grandmaster actually white lost this
game in just two demos but if he plays
the right move he's actually winning
Cora Bob is playing for Ukraine at
Olympiad Cora both neurontin he played
here there is another guy who is coming
to plays kuzu both those different kuzu
both horrible different white to play
and win again this is a challenge
because these are difficult positions
but just take your time and try to
calculate as much as you can this is
going to improve your calculation okay
just calculate everything yeah Ken
that's the movie plate yes takes takes
check sorry can't
yeah you're thinking like a 2600 grandma
said that's not bad and 97 and white the
black adventurer the warm because he's
up a piece well what'd you do honking
what to do yeah so it's not okay for one
okay you Don entire rooked oh so you
need to move take the rook just play it
down a piece the problem I think if you
just do this this this I think is this
right
okay maybe Bishop c3 you have but he
doesn't seem very clear Bishop here
around an is-6
okay it seems like White has a lot of
pressure here but doesn't look
completely clear clear all right
yes
absolutely excellent play Bravo
rook e1 is the winning move amazing yes
you just played like a very strong
grandmaster good job now now let's see
why is this losing okay if he takes
takes check look at the background here
background checkmate alright Bishop is
hanging if you go Knight d7 Bishop takes
f7 so Oh another idea if he goes here
who can point out the winning move here
who can play brilliant huh
which player can play really brilliant
here to win there probably a few other
ways to win but Michael Neal rookie 7
most likely winning absolutely rookie 7
yeah but I want addy better
what other nice move you have here you
can do to deflect this piece here
Caleb there you go and if he takes
excellent excellent job by Caleb sir
well now he goes checked oh this is the
tough part he probably looked at this he
thought check and then 96 he didn't see
anything but he missed something he
overlooked a very important detail here
if you move the King I think he just
plays here Ashish and look f8 okay
absolutely Bishop III nil now he takes
pink pink whenever you have options to
recapture what do you do you think
without Russian because you know even
though rupee three is the most natural
move but when you see a good mouth look
for a better one right Bravo
now he develops the night specified
specify with check specify your check
huh
look at that fantastic checkmate down
entire Queen by the way you down an
entire Queen and you win the game so he
has to play ninety seven to avoid and
now now what are you going to do yes
what do you think no young player
yet he can take what a rookie now and in
this position he has this escape square
with 9f8 okay why don't we put the Queen
somewhere else what do you think
Queen we're perfect very good now he
goes here rook af8 another example when
opponent of the pieces I've just
paralyzed they cannot move anything now
one more neat move and the game is over
one more neat move and white wins the
game here sheesh
good move needed to create a threat
yes in the back
it's not a Quinn move okay it's not a
Quinn move because at the moment you
don't have anything with a queen you
need to bring more peace to build up to
build up more pressure okay yes so
what's the idea here
go ahead yes all right very nice look f1
it's a very nice quiet move okay you
found two moves yeah very good excellent
today yeah now the point here is you're
pressuring here and how can block
untangle here you're just threatening to
take now take everything and mate so the
knight cannot move Queen is hanging so
let's look at Queen d8 now what do you
do you can take knight of seven perfect
now if it takes your Queen night h6
double check mate you see that that will
check with the bishop check with the
night check with the bishop excellent
okay that is fantastic yes so he has to
take back if it takes back with the rook
then you just take the Queen that's game
over right there so it has to go here
with the knight Knight takes f7 and now
what do you do better
look at seven because if it takes your
look you have a queen da check winning
the rook so it has to take back the
Queen rook takes is seven check goes
here rook takes the seven winning the
game okay and at the end we see that
white is upper piece and winning
difficult position see it took some time
to figure out but you have basically
you're in a situation where most of your
pieces are pretty active but you have to
realize which piece is not in the game
and that's the rook on a1 and the threat
is now you want to bring the rook into
the game which you have rook F 1 and you
have route d1 here so that's why you
have to choose between 2 and rook F 1 is
also natural move but then Bishop takes
these six so that's why you have to go
with the move once again let's go over
this again because there are a lot of
interesting lines so what's the winning
move here rook e1 attacking the bishop
if Bishop takes d6 pawn takes the six
Queen takes b6 check same thing like in
a game will result into a checkmate on e
8 so he has to play na Queen d7 and now
you have two winning moves 1s rookie 7
and the second one is Queen B 7 again
Queen cannot be captured because of the
mate on I ate so he plays Bishop d4
check which is the only move now see
many most of the people including this
Grandmaster he probably thought check
and he just thought okay entry to 96 and
he didn't see anything and that's where
he stopped because Bishop e3 it's not an
easy move to see because you're sort of
exchanging pieces while you're down a
rook but by doing that you're improving
which piece the Queen the Queen right
because now you threaten Cooney eight
mate so again if he goes Knight 86 the
difference is he keeps the control of
his seven but he gets mated because of
which idea check check and mate cannot
go back cannot go anywhere so we have 97
and now white is activating his Queen 27
and now look f1 now look at all the
pieces the white pieces are very active
and you know despite being down a rope
here you cannot protect on f7 so I have
to go here Queen d89 takes f7
you're sacrificing your queen actually
here because of which move double check
when double check happens King has to
move and if King cannot move anywhere
that is double check mate this is the
game below gun Cora both this didn't
happen in the game though in the game he
blundered he played he played he played
your move yeah so takes Knight takes f7
and now
wrote xf7 if rook takes f7 d8 is hanging
so now rook g7 is threatened taking
everything here so he he takes he retake
the Queen so he played Queen e7 and now
check-check oh and winning the game all
right
excellent job these two positions we did
are very very hard so it took some time
but you know you guys managed to solve
them and you always want to study
Grandmaster games even though there
might be difficult little bit but
eventually you will get the ideas why
they're playing each move so you guys
did a great job and so we're going to
take a little break now and get ready
for the next class at 7:30 ok thanks for
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]